it's daylight savings time man
did you feel that
what a friggin speed bump that is huh
you know you got regular life going on
everything's chill
you know you maybe you and the lady got
a plan to do a little
you know
do a little
dirty game a close freeze tag with each
other
a little freaking bang bang bang bang
bang
and then suddenly you realize
i got one less hour
of sleep coming at me
and for me man my entire world falls
apart
like everything everything fell apart i
went and bought cigarettes
i bought one of them things of um
you know them six those pudding packs
them snack packs they got
i bought one of them chocolatey hitters
bruh
one of them six pack of chocolatey um
you know uh
jello children's snack packs
and saying dude i'm cracking into those
and
you know blowing winston's
and i'm just going through it all
and now i'm so angry here the crazy
thing was i was so angry that i'm losing
that i'm not going to get an hour of
sleep that now i'm too angry to go to
sleep
so i was just
oh
and then then here's what i'll do i'll
get angry and i'll be like oh i'm oh
okay world
okay world you're gonna take away an
hour of sleep guess what i'm not gonna
brush my teeth tonight
that's this weird game that goes on in
my head you know
like okay universe
you don't want daddy to get that extra
big 60 of nighty night night
then i'm not gonna brush my teeth
you'll see i'm gonna wake up i'm gonna
wake up straight up just spraying that
grim reaper heat
right at people's eyeballs
but that's what that's it you know like
the world gives a [ __ ] that i'm gonna do
that the world doesn't care bruh
go to bed you idiot
but not me not me man i gotta
you know i gotta
i gotta get angry and get crooked
so then i'm bent out
now i'm bent out and i'm you know i've
smoked nine winstons and blew through
five of them kitty snackers
and now i'm a creep now i'm a you know
now the neighbors are look you know and
they have these people who have a a
balcony that's kind of over for mine on
the third floor and they always look
down on me
and it's weird because since they do
like physically look down on me it feels
like they
also look down on me
you know emotionally
and you know subjectively i think i
don't know if those are the right two
words to use there but guess what you
know what i'm talking about you know
so let's don't get each on each other's
backs about all these words
but i feel like they looked down at me
and last night man the lady caught me
man
the lady caught me out there just
leaking with emotion just bent out
you know
just freaking just
just heavy huffing these winstons these
winston cigarettes and
and blowing through that chocolatey six
so yeah i mean i don't you know i don't
fare well with change obviously
you know up front i don't but in the end
i know it's what's best
you know i know change is always the
best man i know it's scary but you know
change is scary but i think it's always
the best
you know i was thinking about
because you know this morning i got up i
didn't get up till probably 11 30
you know because i didn't even get to
bed or probably 3 40
you know in sheer fury and i didn't
brush my teeth
you know even though it just affects me
when i do that [ __ ] but whatever bruh
when i was young
people in my town for daylight saving
time people some people didn't know what
it was
you know in my neighborhood bro they had
some real
they had people [ __ ]
you know definitely a lot of people
sharing ideas like if you wanted an idea
you better go down the street and borrow
it from somebody
you know a lot of people weren't coming
up with their own thoughts
in my neighborhood
and i remember this one dude furious bro
he might have been on some uppers he
might have been drinking out of get out
of a car battery i don't know
you know because they had these dudes
for a while they would empty out a car
battery and then they would put a beer
in there and then drink it out of the
battery so you get a little bit of that
that hit of that battery acid with also
with your beverage
you know and these people were just
you know they were just losing steam man
they were just starting to fall off the
bone
you know because something's getting
wrong with them because of some of that
battery acid and this one dude i
remember daylight savings time came
outside shotgun just started shooting at
the sun
you know [ __ ] this
[ __ ] this
shooting at the sun dude furious bro
couldn't figure it out you know
saying he'd been cheated and all this
[ __ ]
so you never know
you never know what you're gonna get out
there man
you know when i told him i said straight
up man everybody loses the hour that
ain't just you boy
you know you get off your own ego
because everybody loses the damn hour
it's not like you're [ __ ] living in
the future all of a sudden or in the
past
you [ __ ]
muppet
get it together everybody loses the hour
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one